faire des économies tout en faisant un
geste pour la planète c'était l'objectif
de ce deuxième salon de la rénovation
énergétique organisée ce dimanche 14
octobre à la ferme du manet à montils
lebon tenue il y avait un besoin des
particuliers de se renseigner sur cette
thématique parce qu'on entend beaucoup
de choses c'est vraiment en vogue on
entend parler partout mais pour avoir un
conseil précis et qui soit adaptée est
vraiment bien de cette demande de
structures en fait cette année le salon
de composer une thermographie aérienne
gratuite pour les visiteurs et caméras
infrarouges ont survolé en mars les
villes de saint quentin en yvelines pour
effectuer leur diagnostic sur la toiture
des bâtiments
on valide finalement par l'image les
endroits où ils ont pu réaliser des
travaux
et puis al'inverse pour des gens qui au
contraire ont des problèmes d'isolation
la réalisation de la thermographie
aérienne va permettre de précisément
indiquer les endroits où il faut
focaliser les travaux d'isolation un
stand qui a attiré plusieurs centaines
de personnes sur la journée
disons que j'ai déjà été rassurés par le
fait que la thermographie ont montré que
mon logement était déjà clairement bien
isolé après je regardais un petit peu
pour la mise en place éventuellement
d'autres solutions pour produire de
l'énergie ne reste plus qu'aux visiteurs
à se lancer dans un projet de rénovation
énergétique mais cela a un coût entre
10000 et 30000 euros en moyenne